how's it going guys it's Jake and
welcome back to another Elden ring
discussion video today I want to talk
about Shadow of the UR tree because I'm
about 80 to 90% sure that a launch date
will be announced at The Game Awards
this year I mainly think this not only
because I'm coping and because there's
some decent rumors going around that
this will be the case but I just think
it's time it's finally time this has
been a long wait especially for an Elden
ring Channel like myself I wasn't
expecting to get a ton of different
updates throughout Elden Ring's lifespan
but jeez 2 years to wait for a DLC is
pretty insane I remember a year ago I
was making videos saying get your
character ready for DLC soon then after
that I thought it might be possible that
they just weren't going to make a DLC at
all which was entirely possible then we
got the infamous announcement picture
back in February and now just radio
silence since then I never thought it'd
take this long but here we are I've
tried to Branch out to other games a bit
on this channel and if it's not a
soulslike game then the interest is
pretty low and that makes total sense
because this is an Elden ring lore
Channel all success of this channel is
from Elden ring lore videos and changing
the goal of this channel which is to
tell the lore of Elden ring in an
understandable and entertaining way to
something else isn't really fair to you
guys you subscribed for the lore and
changing that up is like going to
McDonald's and seeing that the menu is
only Sushi or something thing I got this
comment recently that says I feel awful
for your channel man Elden ring content
demand has died down and it's sad your
vids have amazing effort put into them
and it deserves more views I appreciate
this comment because it's sort of true
but there's a lot of Elden ring creators
especially the challenge Runners that
are doing great in terms of views and
engagement and they seem like they're
just having a lot of fun making the
content that they do it's something that
I've tried here on the channel a couple
of times and hasn't gone as well as I'd
like to but you know it is what it is
comparison is the thief of Joy I really
hope this isn't coming off as a wo is me
type of thing that's not what I'm trying
to say here but what I mean by all of
this is just that my goals and the
audience's goals have shifted I don't
like looking at analytics but when you
are a YouTuber you kind of have to and
lore discussion videos and keeping it in
the souls likee genre is clearly what
you guys want so I'm not going to fight
against that anymore I'm thankful for
what I have I'm thankful I had any
success at any point so instead of
fighting against it all the time I'm
just going to do what's best in the
field that works meaning I'm not going
to attempt shifting anymore I can start
a totally new channel if that's
something I really want to do but you
are here for the lore on Souls like
games and when this DLC comes out I
guarantee we'll have a lot to talk about
and it'll be fun to make videos on again
a couple weeks ago I asked you guys
where do you think shadow of the earth
tree is going to take the story within m
dream back in time to before the
shattering or to a completely new area
while there were a ton of different
answers to this question mainly everyone
is set on the story focusing on Mika
which I 100% agree with this is clearly
mola in the shadow of the Ury
announcement picture and I've also had
the already popular theory that will'll
be inside micha's dream we'll get to
unravel the full story of what happened
before the shattering what happened to
the family of demigods that put them in
the states we find them all in and what
really happened to Micha in the first
place to be snatched from his Halo tree
and used by Moog we've been talking
about all these topics for years now at
this point we have all thrown our
theories Into the Fire and tried to
match it all together but for me I have
always had this lingering strange
feeling it's a difficult feeling to
describe because it comes and goes the
more I play Elden ring I put in 1,400
hours into the game and I just can't
shake the feeling that none of the world
we play the game in is real well it's a
video game Jake of course it's not real
but you know what I mean the lands
between doesn't feel like a real place
to me it feels like a mosh poot of
different timelines events and
circumstances all folding into itself it
feels real but also not at the same time
it feels familiar but also completely
unique it feels to me like we're already
in a dream which is really only
something I've started to consider
recently have you yourself ever had a
dream where you were thrown into a
situation that you didn't fully
understand but went along with anyway
maybe you were at school and you were
told that you had a test today that you
didn't study for then you frantically
start searching your backpack for a
study guide to go off of or maybe at
work you were told that you need to have
a presentation ready to present to the
company that you didn't know about till
this very moment then you wake up
hopeful that you don't go to school
anymore and don't have a job to me this
sounds a lot like when we come into the
lands between awakened by grace to
complete the impossible task of
gathering great runes by defeating
literal demigods in hopes of mending the
Elden ring and becoming Elden Lord which
are all things we don't fully understand
but just do because we were told to I've
always looked at the Landscaping of the
lands between as a weird sign of this as
well it's just a giant Island that
almost seems folded into itself to
compress all of these different
important landmarks and events into one
place not to mention that you have to
cross the fog whatever that means to
even come to the lands between I believe
it's possible we are already in mola's
dream which is really his nightmare
situation for the place he grew up in
his family and obviously himself the
land between when we play the game is in
complete disarray Wars are are still
being fought powerful characters are
losing their minds demigod siblings are
still fighting for power or obsessed
with it micha's objective to help those
being oppressed by the influence of the
her tree his halic tree has died his
sister has been waiting for him to
return only for her to wait in silence
for who knows how long rotting away
under his failed halig tree Mika was
supposed to create a new world a new
life for those who chose to follow him
only for him to seemingly disappear from
his followers not to mention his body
his blood is being used for moog's new
Dynasty basically everything going on in
the lands between points to a complete
nightmare situation for mola and we all
know that in every item description we
can find that mentions Mika it says how
he is loved by many and he has learned
very well how to compel such affection
what if Mika is the one who created us
within his dream what if he's the one
that guides us throughout our journey
journey in hopes that we can find him
and wake him up we'd be the hero of this
dream and it would make a lot of sense
that we'd end up conquering all of these
incredible odds and eventually becoming
Elden Lord just like we do when we beat
the game however dreams work in weird
ways like I mentioned earlier you could
almost know that you are in a dream but
will sometimes still go with the flow of
the dream itself if that makes sense
you'll still follow the path that the
dream has created for you to experience
and other times you'll go off this path
entirely creating Your Own Story within
the dream just like almost all of us do
when we play the game we can either
follow the path entirely or we can go
off and do our own adventure this is a
difficult Theory to explain but is
something I believe most people will
sort of relate with in terms of Dreams
and Nightmares there are times during a
nightmare where you understand that you
are in a nightmare but you still can't
wake yourself up you just can't quite
get your eyes to open from the dream I
believe that this is the situation Nia
is in in his own nightmare he can't wake
up from it but instead goes with the
flow of the story within the nightmare
creating us to hopefully wake him up by
becoming Elden Lord and changing the
world just like he wanted to could this
be why we look up toward micholas Halo
tree when we defeat millenia's first
stage I've always found this to be very
strange why is our character looking up
towards this trunk where Micha cocoon
was removed maybe we feel some sort of
strong connection toward it I believe
the DLC will be us touching this hand of
Mika and not entering into micha's dream
but waking him up from it and us being
transferred along with him to the real
lands between that looks a lot like the
picture we see here the land covered in
reads ruined buildings and the Earth
tree being completely taken over by
Godwin's death blight I believe we'll
work with Micha to defeat Godwin's
deadly influence save whatever remains
of the lands between and help him plant
a new tree molas halic tree this
probably goes without saying but I
believe this DLC will be massive
basically reskinning the entire
Overworld for us to explore again with
completely new things to discover
there's a lot going on with this Theory
it's a wild one I know but I've been
asked many times recently what I think
the cont of the DLC will be and this
video is my answer to that question
there's holes in this Theory but
honestly there's a lot of holes in every
theory that looks beyond just the base
information that the game gives us this
is just my guess and I believe it's a
good one I'll be live streaming the game
awards here on YouTube so do all the
good YouTube stuff so you don't miss a
new upload or any live stream I do on
here I'm still streaming those challenge
runs by the way even though they don't
do particularly well because well
they're fun to do let me know what you
guys think of this Theory and I'll make
a follow video discussing it all with
you thanks for watching and I will see
you again in the next one take care